curious about the innovation at work
prototyping workshop here's what you can
expect
so in this workshop you'll actually do
two things one is you'll spin your team
up on the skills of prototyping and the
second thing you'll do is you'll
actually forward a project at work
within the session a lot of people think
that prototyping is only applicable to
teams that make physical products but
that's not true at all we believe that
the tools and attitudes of prototyping
can be applied to anything regardless of
what your team's output is whether you
make experiences whether you make
meetings whether you make communications
whether you make services or physical
products or digital products anything
can be prototyped and we want you to
bring that open-mindedness to this
session not only thinking about physical
products as what could be prototypes so
and how this works if you're watching
this video we think of you as a catalyst
the person that's gonna actually pull
together this session this workshop and
make it happen and rest assured within
the context of this this course or
workshop we actually have the pieces
that you need to be successful catalyzed
in this session you don't need to bring
anything to the session you don't need
to have done any of the other innovation
work workshops to do this all you need
to pull off an innovation at work
prototyping workshop is a care for your
team to see them grow in their ability
to realize ideas and put them into the
world in a powerful way